Jeff asks you've been called the
American Tolkien how do you do you feel
that that's a fair comparison I'm
feeling a strange sense of deja vu yeah
[Laughter]
I'm very flattered to be called the
American Tolkien it's a the greatest
compliment you can give any fantasy
writer Tolkien
touken essentially created modern
fantasy fantasy and of course that
existed before Tolkien it goes all the
way back to you know Gilgamesh and and
Homer but modern fantasy in the shape
that we're familiar with it understands
today is all following in the footsteps
of Tolkien
that being said I'm a very different
writer than token where were products of
very different times he was born in the
19th century a product of English
society at a particular point in time he
served and fought in the trenches of
World War one he was a world-class
linguist and Oxford dawn of academic
persuasion he he wrote his books largely
I think for his own amusement and the
amusement of his children where he had
some particular passions of his like
creating artificial languages I sure
none of that I mean I'm a baby boomer
born in 1948 they come from a
blue-collar background in Bayonne New
Jersey lived in federal housing projects
was involved in the opposition to the
Vietnam War and have have largely told
stories and and written as a as a
professional writer for most of my adult
life I have great admiration for Tolkien
but my work is in no sense tolkien-esque
except in the sense of being a secondary
world fantasy but I'm still flattered by
the comparison I mean it's you know I'm
being compared to one of the greatest
that ever was and who could who could
object to that
how did you come up with the idea they
this person Amanda wants to know why you
decided these different perspectives
character perspectives
Jeff from chapter to chapter what made
you make that decision uh well I have a
very big story to tell it's an epic
story it takes place over several
continents and a relatively long period
of time and it involves complex politics
and war and other things like that
so there's no one possible single
character that could possibly tell the
entire story he'd be experiencing part
of it but the rest of it would be
occurring on a different continent or on
a different half of Westeros he'd be
just hearing about it in a letter or or
report so obviously you need more than a
single viewpoint character and the other
way to go would be omniscient viewpoint
where I'm just God and and I'm looking
down at the players but omniscient
viewpoint I've never liked that as a
reader I think we don't experience none
of us are God when we experience life we
we see it through a particular viewpoint
you know I'm looking at you you're
looking at me when I'm we're not above
looking down on the two of us here you
know you don't see if someone was
sneaking up behind you with a knife you
wouldn't necessarily see that person but
I might so it makes a huge difference in
who's new point we we tell that
particular incident from that's the way
we experience life that's the way we
should experience fiction I believe
so therefore with given the size of the
story and my belief about third person
view point being the way to do it a
series of third-person viewpoint so you
could present all sides of a large
canvas was a logical way to go all right